un sommet de la francophonie qui réuni
84 états et gouvernements parce que par
exemple il ya des pays où il ya à la
fois le pays des gouvernements régionaux
comme celui de wallonie par exemple qui
sont représentés ça va durer deux jours
ce sommet alors il ya un thème
consensuel en diable ça s'appelle vivre
ensemble dans la solidarité je ne sais
plus très bien quoi est ce que c'est
encore à quelque chose la francophonie
aujourd'hui à part à ceux à se réunir et
à faire des grands discours d'un sens du
jeu d'abord j'observe que emmanuel
macron éprouvent moins de difficultés à
remanier la tête de la francophonie et
de l'onef que son gouvernement alors ça
va y venir après féthi riah au
changement éventuel de patron
où on verra d'ailleurs qu' il y à la
dictature français qui est un peu
paradoxale passons mais pour un moment
la francophonie suscite en général des
proclamations tout à fait louable moi
j'aime beaucoup cette novlangue andy les
pays qui ont le français en partage
amen j'observe aussi que vous avez des
association un peu insolite là on va
discuter par exemple d'un statut de
membres associés observateurs pour
l'arabie saoudite
j'aimerais savoir quel est le
pourcentage de saoudiens qui pratiquent
la langue française on a vu passer le
qatar pour des raisons qui n'ont pas
grand chose à voir avec la langue de
molière
enfin et c'est retire donc il ya une
vraie difficulté à redéfinir une
francophonie moderne
alors on nous dit dans l'entourage de
manuel macron oui approche décrispé et
c'est ce que veut pas dire grand chose
et puis il ya un autre souci c'est que
soul experience sénégalais abdou diouf
qui a accompli trois mandats à la tête
de l'eau y est fabien et celle interne à
la francophonie
il y a eu la fichage d'une volonté
politique au sens d'être aussi un
instrument de démocratie agissante
or là dessus franchement il ya encore
des progrès à faire par exemple je cite
que ce cas à ce stade j'ai croisé il ya
quelques jours un député français qui
est membre de la mission d'observation
de l'oif f pour les élections du
cameroun qui était effectivement et
selon une tradition tenace une mascarade
dimanche dernier quand il vous explique
dans quelles conditions il a été
sollicité former ou plutôt pas fort mais
sa date d'arrivée sa date de départ vous
dit attendez si on a un message
francophone spécifiques en termes de
maturité politique et démocratique
il fallait s'y prendre autrement donc a
vraiment un lien réel flottement là
dessus donc vous n'avez pas l'air
convaincu de l'utilité de ce de ce
dispositif frédéric saint clair vous non
plus ou bien vous trouvez ça bien la
francophonie avant on disait ça permet à
la france d'être influente
aujourd'hui on est plus à du tout pour
les une raison assez simple c'est qu'en
réalité les canaux du soft power passe
par beaucoup d'autres
instrument j'allais dire outils que
celui de la langue aujourd'hui 10 soft
power on dit pas pouvoir
d'ailleurs elle même la traduction c'est
une puissance douce je pense qu'elle est
mauvaise donc traduction française
puissant souple sont plus adaptées donc
le la francophonie à l'époque où la
france avait vocation à devenir un
empire était absolument essentiel parce
que de partager une langue ça permet
d'adhérer un socle de valeurs communes
aujourd'hui c'est absolument pas le cas
on est même al'inverse de ça dans le
respect des cultures indigènes à la fois
à l'extérieur et à l'intérieur des
frontières nationales dont condé
j'allais dire à l'opposé de ce qu'a pu
être la france jusqu'au début du 20e
siècle
je vois mal aujourd'hui la francophonie
comme un outil permettant de
contrebalancer la domination de
l'anglais comme langue internationale
s'est absolument pas crédible non plus
donc oui pour l'entretenir si ça permet
d'entretenir des liens amicaux et de
resserrer pourquoi pas les intérêts
entre pays j'y crois honnêtement assez
peu après et vous damien le guay vous y
croyez est-ce que l'avenir de quand même
c'est le français l'une des langues les
plus parlées dans le monde c'est un
motif de fierté non de fierté
gigantesque et le fait de pouvoir
proposer ce qui était le cas
effectivement de des empires ii de
pouvoir proposer comme ça le français
comme une langue de référence et nous
sommes aussi une ambition absolument
gigantesque est génial le seul problème
me semble t'il quand regard un peu le
sujet c'est que ça a été mêlé avec des
problèmes politiques
on a voulu faire de la francophonie
quelque chose de politique comme si
derrière la langue
il y avait aussi des valeurs politiques
communes et donc tout là toute la sauce
du
bien vivre ensemble du partage des
droits de l'homme qui était rare
effectivement on est dit que en afrique
ou ailleurs
chacun se débrouille avec sa culture ou
ses habitudes politiques propres mais
qu'on ne partage pas des valeurs qui
sont comme donc le fait d'avoir mélangé
tout à peut-être et mon avis
certainement diminuer la vocation
première de la francophonie à savoir
développer des instituts donner des
moyens les budgets tous ces éléments là
qui permettent de faire la promotion de
la langue et malheureusement force est
de constater que ses moyens financiers
là sont en diminution constante et que
nous n'avons pas les moyens de notre
ambition et les moyens qui devraient
normalement revenir à la promotion de la
langue parce que tous ces moyens là
diminue donc ça c'est la première chose
la deuxième chose c'est que si les
français ou si la france défend d elle
même ne serait-ce que dans un autre
façon de parler
un respect scrupuleux de la langue et en
évitant de se faire francs francs gliese
et franglo mobiliser d'accepter comme
cela en permanence dans le discours
public dans à la télévision tous et
toutes tous ces mots anglais qui n'ont
rien à faire ici peut-être qu'on aurait
une meilleure idée de ce qu'est la
francophonie et de la promotion de la
langue française qui est effectivement
on peut le dire parce que nous
partageons tous là la plus belle longue
du monde
leila aichi c'est une question de moyens
comme le comme le disait damien le guay
aussi de faire vivre la francophonie oui
évidemment ont significativement c'est
une question de moyens une question
celle de marat manque d'argent comme
c'est une question de demande
volonté politique j'aurais pas un
constat aussi aussi négatifs dont
contraire moi je trouve que c'est que
c'est utile c'est un outil pour la
diplomatie du soft power certes il ya
quand même plus de 230 millions
d'individus sur la terre dont sur la
planète qui parlent le français d'ici
2050 on en aura 770 millions je n'ai pas
non plus cette vision catastrophique et
est négative une langue à la vocation à
vivre donc à subir les influences du
monde extérieur toutes les langues se
sont construites de cette manière hier
aujourd'hui et demain et c'est je pense
également contrairement ce qu'il va puer
dit autour de cette table
moi je reste à penser que
l'apprentissage et le fait que beaucoup
de peuples dans le monde parle le
français c'est aussi un bien est un
vecteur de véhiculer notre culture
quand on apprend une langue on n'apprend
pas simplement un moyen de communiquer
on apprend aussi ses valeurs son
histoire sa culture et sa une influence
évidemment certaines et si je venais
enfin si on peut on pousser le
raisonnement jusqu'au bout
si on venait à fermer enfin à venir
fermer le la francophonie à faire en
sorte que ça n'existe plus quelle serait
notre levier de de commandes ird
influence et je pense que justement face
aline l'omniprésence de l'anglais du
fait que la totalité des pays du monde
parle l'anglais au détriment du français
fait que justement c'est un outil qui
mérite effectivement d'être améliorée
pour plusieurs raisons effectivement
manque de moyens peut-être un manque
d'ambition réel aussi il n'y a pas de
volonté
c'est un levier à mon avis qui n'est pas
suffisamment exploité la francophonie il
ya vous aviez une 1 comment dire
une vision négative que l'arabie
saoudite ou d'autres pays frappent à la
porte qui veulent apprendre le français
pourquoi pas why not je sais pas si vous
avez suivi le cas par exemple de bahreïn
à bahreïn en fait ils ont sont
d'ailleurs mon fils influence de
l'ancien ambassadeur qui a été très
francophone avec une épouse parfaitement
francophone ont influencé de sorte que
les enfants à bahreïn je sais pas si
vous le savez apprennent le français
obligatoirement à l'école primaire mais
moi je trouve ça génial ça c'est un jeu
c'est un cétacé saoudite entre ces temps
j'ai pas dit que c'était c'était bien
mais c'est un jeu d'influencés on ferme
la porte on ferme la porte à notre
culture à nos valeurs et à ce que
justement on veut porter donc je dis pas
forcément l'arabie saoudite est pas un
pays francophone nous sommes d'accord ce
poste a rappelé question de la série je
ne fais pas partie de la francophonie
par exemple oui alors pour le coup
évidemment sa plainte
non mais je pense qu'il faire la part
des choses entre une sorte d'esthétique
élitaire de l'aristocratie locale pour
qui ça reste quand même très chic
alexandrie ou ailleurs dans les six
enfants dans une école francophone et ce
qu'est la véritable existence au
quotidien de cette langue et cette
culture dans une population ciblée pour
nuancer quand un peu le tableau ce qui
est vrai et ça je tiens à le souligner
c'est que j'ai rencontrés dix fois cent
fois un jeune congolais à kinshasa une
jeune irakienne à bagdad pour qui
l'alliance française
le centre culturel français la pratique
de la langue était un véritable espace
de liberté liberté sociale liberté
politique donc je serai le dernier à
nier cette réalité mais le problème
c'est pas ça c'est que précisément ont
ce qu'on voit aujourd'hui la tendance
pour des raisons éminemment budgétaire
ce qu on a plutôt tendance à supprimer
des postes et à fermer des aînés en
français les centres culturels donc que
la francophonie comme idéal porteur de
valeurs
soit à coups de sommet au pinacle très
bien mais ce qui est plus important me
semble-t-il c'est cette francophonie du
quotidien avec notamment l'alliance
française
on vous a posé la question sur twitter
un selon vous la francophonie at elle un
avenir et vous êtes 59% à nous répondre
oui quelques commentaires à l'aïs qui
nous dit tant qu'on continuera de parler
cette langue française la francophonie
aura toujours de beaux jours devant elle
olympe e livre son témoignage pour bien
connaître la situation du français au
canada
cette langue est malmené au québec et w
qui nous dit on nous fait croire à
travers la francophonie que nous sommes
encore une grande nation alors que nous
ne le sommes plus depuis bien longtemps
vraiment effectivement on essaie de
répondre à cette question encore un mot
là-dessus le ce sommet est aussi
l'occasion d'une nouvelle élection à la
tête de l'organisation internationale de
la francophonie
il ya une ce crétin générale sortante
qui s'appelle michaëlle jean qui est
haïtienne sauf erreur de ma part qui se
représentent
voilà il ya un canadien d'origine
haïtienne merci de le préciser
et puis il ya une autre candidate qui
est la ministre des affaires étrangères
du rwanda qui semble-t-il est soutenue
par la france
on va éclaircir ça après en tout cas ce
qui est sûr c'est que ça déplaît
profondément à marine le pen écoutez là
c'est la décision d' emmanuel macron
semble-t-il de soutenir à la tête de
l'organisation internationale de la
francophonie
une ministre de kagamé violemment
antifrançaises violemment antifrançaises
qui explique qu'il faut pas parler
français qu'il faut parler anglais que
ça amène beaucoup plus loin que le
français kagame qui a fait jour appelle
raser le centre culturel français kigali
à 4 ans kamel président rwandais est ce
que cette accusation est légitime et
justifiée
vincent un jeu outrancière comme
d'habitude de s'agissant de l'oratrice
convient d'écouter dans revenons
simplement à la vérité des faits
l'engagement français auprès de louise
mushikiwabo donc ministre des affaires
étrangères infiniment loyal à paul
kagame a quelque chose de profondément
baroque
pourquoi parce que le 23 mai dernier
paul kagame sur le perron de l'elysée
annoncé promeut cette candidature dans
la langue de shakespeare
bon sérieusement ravir le rwanda la
langue officielle est l'anglais j'ajoute
que depuis 2009 la longue
iter d'enseignement à partir du primaire
n'est plus le français mais et l'anglais
et c'est évidemment là encore une
posture qui est intégralement politique
et qui renvoie au caractère exécrable de
la relation bilatérale notamment depuis
le génocide de 1994 au passage on
soulignera que paris n'a pas jugé utile
d'envoyer un ambassadeur à kigali
aujourd'hui simplement quand vous
objecter cela à l'entourage
emmanuel macron on vous dit mais il ne
s'agit pas d'une relation bilatérale il
s'agit de quelqu'un qui est opérationnel
qui a l'expérience qui associe qui à
cela mais quand même il est tout à fait
légitime de prétendre que l'avenir de la
francophonie se joue aussi en afrique
très bien que donc le poste pourquoi pas
il était occupé par l'égyptien boutros
boutros ghali puis par le sénégalais
abdou diouf peut ou doit revenir à un
africain africaine pourquoi pas mais
franchement l'afrique n'a pas d'autre
candidat à proposer que quelqu'un qui a
porté une parole de citer alors ayant
dit cela je ne peux pas être suspect de
complaisance pour l'ancien régime rang
des gt1 des gens et de france et
d'ailleurs à quelques confrères du
figaro qui ont été les plus offensifs
sur la responsabilité historique
ne serait ce que par cette cécité
volontaire de la france dans le génocide
de 94 donc c'est pas le problème
c'est simplement que le message qui est
convoyée par ce soutien s'ajoute le
lâchage dans les grandes largeurs sans
qu'on ait venir m'en compris quels sont
les griefs adressés à la sortante
il ya quand même quelque chose là qui
est tout à fait insolite et bien voilà
un point éclairci il nous reste quelques
minutes pour parler d'une information
révélée ce matin par nos confrères du
canard enchaîné le patron de force
ouvrière pascal pavageau qui était en
campagne avec anti l'excellent campagne
pardon pour succéder à jean-claude
mailly avait mis en fiches en tout cas
si ce n'est lui c'est son équipe de
collaborateurs plus de 100 cadres de
force ouvrière avec des fiches
extrêmement précises avec la photo le
numéro de téléphone portable mais
surtout des mentions assez précises
genre anarchiste francs-maçons ce qui
prouve qu'on ne l'est pas forcément
quand on est à force ouvrière plus d'une
année